ser diferente é normal e normais ser
diferente
só na maioria das crianças é muitas
vezes pra disney
conheci o mickey a minnie as princesas
ser uma princesa um super herói em um
setor e quem é que já não pensou em
povoar a mente das pessoas
vou voltar no tempo pois é meu sonho
sempre foi um pouco diferente
meu sonho sempre foi ter um irmãozinho
ser diferente é normal e normais ser
diferente
eu tenho uma irmã que é um ano e oito
meses mais velho do que mesmo com uma
diferença tão pequena de idade a gente
uma diferença muito grande de
comportamento
parece que eu terei de infinita queria
fazer de tudo o que podia principalmente
que não podia sabe-tudo mesa queria
correr brincar e eu sentia falta de
companhia para essas coisas eu e minha
irmã gente sempre brincava mas ela
sempre foi mais de lei e assistir
televisão e eu querendo correr ainda
dava eu percebi que os meninos eram mais
dispostos mais parecido comigo e com o
que eu precisava
eu pensei assim já pensou se eu tivesse
alguém que brincasse bagunçasse topasse
as minhas loucuras e ainda escutar seus
sermões comigo
enfeite esse é o meu pedido que os meus
pais
em todas as ocasiões eu queria um irmão
um simples pois é gente quando tinha
cinco anos de idade
eu fiquei sabendo que ia terminar foi
realizado em uma grávida ou
e eu eu ia teu irmão
a gente já tem tudo planejado os dias
que a gente jogar futebol
o dia que a gente olhar de card tudo o
que a imaginação em compreensível não
vive em constante esta alegria tudo um
pouco se ele foi quando uma complicação
na gestação e acabou perdendo o bebê no
sétimo mês
naquela época eu nunca li trabalhou com
cinco anos de idade não estava preparado
para ver o meu sonho tão próximo da
realidade acabasse
[Música]
foi então eu comecei a ter problemas
emocionais e com isso eu não sabia que
era uma criança de 5 anos estava triste
eu não queria conversar com ninguém
eu prefiro guardar pra mim assim meu
corpo começou a se atacar com uma mancha
de discreta na pálpebra do meu olho eu
descobri a vítima desde o início da
doença
meus pais me ofereceram todos os tipos
de tratamento e medicamento fosse eles
os mais simples como as ervas medicinais
até hoje em alta complexidade como as
sessões de laser
alguns deles então resultado no início
mas outros nem isso mas minha mãe sempre
me disse uma coisa que é melhor eu tinha
que ver por dentro daquela época
isso pra mim não sei de nada fazer
diferença
pois é à medida que retira aumentava as
minhas amizades diminuíram
quem é querer uma menina que era toda
manchada fazer tudo piorou quando alguma
das crianças descobriram que era
engraçado a pele das pessoas que eram
diferentes
foi aí que recebeu o apelido de vaca
malhada e se opôs elogio acabou piorando
ainda mais
as obras minhas poucas amizades menina
manchada e ainda chamar de vaca malhada
ninguém
com o tempo eu desenvolvi uma técnica
algumas das coisas que eu tinha doces
brinquedos era de interesse de algumas
das crianças
isso acaba atraindo as pessoas se iam
ficar acompanhando os segredos que dar
um jeito de pegar um doce
dava pra alguém e assim ficava
acompanhada no recreio
então levava brinquedos e deixados nus
brincarem e assim foi
só que não é todo dia que eu tinha um
doce
afinal de contas eu só queria me matar
de açúcar e não é todo dia que a escola
deixar levar brinquedos ou seja não é
todo dia que eu ficava acompanhado pela
boleia outro jeito é dar um jeito de
pegar escondido o dinheiro da minha mãe
da minha volta o meu vôo levava para a
escola e lá eu comprava as amizades com
maneira essa farsa toda drop pouco tempo
eu fui descoberto
pois é ele se dava tarde nessa época e
foi descoberta de manhã
foi uma reunião com meus amigos ler o
dia inteiro juntou eu vou-me avó
meu outro avô meus pares e dá-lhes irmão
da atriz irmã
nesse dia eu perdi a aula e nesse dia
tinha uma prova de matemática ótimo caso
envolver a escola eo pai de alguns
amigos que compram o que você acha que
aconteceu eu vou voltar à estaca zero a
zero amigos pois é no 5º ano
essa prova que eu perdi meu cabelo para
recuperação e essa recuperação levou uma
reprovação falar a verdade eu senti uma
mistura imensa decentes sente tristeza
de perder uma hora e de meus pais
sofrendo alegria poder estar das pessoas
que eu que me aceitava que ela
explicasse melhor eu com nove anos de
idade o final das duas colegas de sala
eu escrevi pra quê basquete a gente
gasta energia cabeça aprovada e lá eu
descobri o desenvolve habilidades
esportivas sociais basquete acabou lhe
dando maior liberdade autoconfiança e
ampliar meus horizontes e lá eu tinha
conhecido pessoas que eram mais novas
que eu do ano abaixo
eu fiz novas amizades com as pessoas que
me aceitava
eu só queria ficar perto delas mas nem
tudo são flores nessa vida mas em
catorze competição eu colégio disputa de
terceiro lugar
o outro tinha uma torcida ia buscar uma
forma de me estabilizar e começar a
cantar a galinha pintadinha pra mim
preparada para arremessar lance livre
falta só será a sexta
você começa a escutar galinha pintadinha
kabuki mas é um sentimento de raiva
tristeza que eu sentia
além da vontade de chorar e missa eu só
queria acertar e falar para eles não me
atingiu
vocês não me atingiram pois é o primeiro
lance livre é rei
na segunda eu acertei já foi suficiente
para que seja estável para o resto da
partida pois é ser diferente é normal eo
normal é ser diferente em 2016
eu fui pra cuba com os meus pais que a
mesma mais uma vez em busca de um
tratamento mais uma vez quem tentando
fazer com que a sociedade teve esse
normal normal
mais uma vez que entanto ter mais amigos
então é normal
vocês são normais pois é eu conseguir
seguir o tratamento à risca por um ano
até que eu percebi que as coisas ruins a
gente pode tirar aprendizados que tudo
bem por um motivo mel no início foi
muito mal pra mim mas ele me dizia quem
o som informou outras pessoas e se não
fosse ele que provavelmente seria pessoa
que me chamou de vaca malhada e em campo
quer limitar dia pra mim então eu só
tenho a agradecer vitiligo veio
pressionar mesmo buscando a cura
eu nunca chegar e mesmo que eu consegui
tirar o vitiligo de mim e assim só
externo e tiggo ele interno
eu tenho 25 a 14 anos mx há 14 anos a
pergunta por que eu
eu só consegui achar 12 anos e depois
muitas coisas acontecem na nossa vida
isso é só um exemplo das diversas e
diversidade
a gente não pode se repetir e se não
fosse
se não fossem eles se eu fosse ele eu
não estaria aqui hoje não sei que eu só
queria desistir 14 anos já teria
executado alguns meus muitos planos de
ser citado
graças a deus foi um amor que recebi
deles foi maior e você só tem a
agradecer
não é porque passaram 14 anos com
vitiligo que agora eu tô dizendo as
agressões
eu sei que ela não está presente em a
minha vida toda
tem muita gente que não tem um motivo
pra isso não tem uma justificativa mas
eles fazem assim então desde 2014
eu achei que já estava acostumada nessas
situações a receber
só que eu percebi que eu tô fazendo de
errado
foi assim que eu consegui seguir a vida
17 anos quando eu estava andando no
shopping
eu sofri uma nova agressão estava
andando no shopping voltou da escola de
boa
por três meninos quando eu passei
falaram que era um nojo que eu era feia
e quer finalizar sair desfilando uma
pessoa ligada em piedade não de alegria
para eles nem olhar para trás
passei até hoje não sei se a minha
reação foi a série d
só sei que eu passei como se não fosse
comigo cheguei em casa para minha mãe e
comecei a jogar esse ano já aconteceu de
novo foi virtual
nada muito diferente a cada hora uma
coisa só muda as palavras sempre a mesma
coisa só que eu já percebi esse ano eu
já estou muito mais madura
eu já nem sei como eu sou aquela frase
minha mãe dizia no início melhor que vem
de dentro
ela veio melhor que eu sou assim
assim ninguém vai me tirar isso
continuar sendo assim o resto da minha
vida e eu vou incentivar a todo mundo
que sofre com algum tipo de agressão a
nos render não está fazendo nada de
errado não é com você
o problema não é você então é isso por
isso que eu tenho uma frase que ser
diferente é normal e normais ser
diferente
essa frase gente ela falou por si senhor
não precisa explicar todo mundo é
diferente
ninguém é igual então a gente não pode
cobrar que a pessoa seja parecida ou
igual a você não vai ser
são essas diferenças que nos transforma
e nos unem a gente tem que aprender a
valorizar respeitar e entender todas
elas
obrigado
i